[Música]
[Aplausos]
no dia 1º de maio de 2014
eu chutei o balde da publicidade largar
o emprego que eu tinha carteira fixa
ironicamente no dia do trabalhador para
uma direção que eu não sabia com o que é
hoje dois anos quase dois anos depois eu
tô aqui no palco do tedx contar um pouco
da história de como eu reúne mais de 300
pessoas dentre esses 120 produtores
locais em uma comunidade
essa comunidade se chama moka a nota é a
primeira loja colaborativa do brasil com
aceleração de produtores locais
mas mais do que tudo isso a boca é uma
comunidade é uma rede de produtores que
se apoiam se aceleram juntos e mais um
tanto de que a ajuda urgente acelerar
essa galera e aí nesse caminho lá de
quando eu tinha uma carteira assinada
até hoje eu jamais imaginaria que tudo o
que que aconteceu na morte que eu ajudei
a construir um terceiro dia
sinto me ensinou e vou contar um pouco
pra vocês o que é que eu aprendi
construindo essa comunidade
a primeira lição é do propósito do dia
15 do ano passado a gente colocou um
posto no ar é esse post
a gente gosta de chamar de fosse mágico
ele tinha a intenção de colocar pitar 35
marcas para criar uma loja de natal em
um mês ea gente recebeu mais de 138
inscritos
foi uma coisa que surpreendeu a gente e
que provou que quando tem uma boa idéia
e um bom propósito as pessoas acreditam
nele com você mesmo que elas não se
conheça elas estão dispostas a se juntar
para fazer algo maior a acontecer
a segunda lição foi abundante que é
muito importante quando se está
construindo uma comunidade a quando o
produtor está sozinho tentando construir
sua marca e desenvolver o seu negócio é
difícil realizar as coisas
é difícil conseguir mercados e não tem
todas as habilidades e precisa para
desenvolver um negócio mas quando está
dentro de uma rede todo seu acesso a
ferramentas habilidades e expertise
e na moda a gente materialize de uma
forma muito simples é uma parede
dispositivo de um lado eles colocam tudo
o que eles têm a habilidade um espaço
vago material do outro que eles precisam
e não passa de mágicas coisa se conectam
um produtor que entende gestão
financeira ajuda o outro organizar a
empresa financeiramente um que tem uma
marcenaria e ajuda o outro criar um
produto e por aí vai
a outra lição que aprendi a empatia
quando você tem uma comunidade unida por
um propósito comum elas como começam a
perceber coisas que elas têm em comum
no caso da rede de produtores eles têm
as mesmas dores
os mesmos sonhos então eles enxergam
muito nos outros e é isso abre uma porta
muito legal que é a confiança
eles querem se ajudar e querem ser
ajudados que ele sabe como é estar
naquele lugar
então essa rede cria a confiança cria um
laço muito mais forte ea confiança é a
moeda principal da economia colaborativa
é o que acho que une as pessoas pra
colaborar entre si e na maioria das
vezes sem esperar nada em troca
então tá aí uma mini receita de bolo de
como construir uma comunidade tem um
propósito connect as abundâncias
construa empatia e confiança parece
fácil mas não é
tem uma coisa muito mais importante que
sem ela nada dessas quatro itens
acontece é uma coisa que dá para tirar
qualquer coisa do papel a qualquer
comunidade ea trabalho e aí isso tudo
que eu contei parece simples é um post
mágica para dispor city mas não é uma
canção nasceu porque eu passei um ano em
cubano ela quando planejam ano esses
anos mas em todos os ramos de negócio
trocar uma idéia passa motos noites em
claro deu muito trabalho
aquele posto de mágico teve 50 versões
para acontecer
e além dessas 50 versões eu tenho
experiência em redação publicitária sou
formado em comunicação social tendo
gravado
são como na social e trabalha em
agências então tudo que eu construí
trabalhei pedra me ajudou a escrever
esse post não foi mágico foi trabalho
aquela parede deposite ela não estava no
lugar sólida parede
foi um fim de semana inteiro de workshop
aceleração pro 12 horas que 37 marcas
locais se uniram para trabalhar
incessantemente nos próprios negócios
então é claro que as conexões das
mudanças de escola eo acontecer e aí um
mês depois que a gente começou a ser
shop a gente construir uma loja no dia
10 de novembro a loja abriu e eu lembro
de ter chegado no dia da inauguração
pensado nossa aqui tá pronto eu não
tinha contrato com ninguém não existia
nada que nos conectar se de uma forma
obrigatória para realizar alguma coisa
estava ali muito melhor do que eu
imaginava e não só esporte
eles passaram um mês trabalhando que a
gente gosta de falar do rabo na boca e
tinham marcas que nem existiam eles
tiveram um desafio de um mês criar nome
identidade visual produto tudo do zero e
eu te pergunto essa confiança que eles
criaram essa comunidade que se
fortaleceu
não foi porque eles foram suas casas do
placar do outro
foi porque eles trabalharam juntos e
isso é muito poderoso e a pergunta a
comunidade da móoca foi mágica foi
trabalho é verdade um conceito que eu
esbarrei nele
alguns meses depois de começar a moka
que a prática deliberada da risotto som
é o pesquisador da do processo criativo
ele já entrevistou milhares de pessoas
ao redor do mundo e tem uma coisa que
pedi foi em comum com todos eles
é a prática deliberada nada mais é do
que a performa tanto aquilo gostar tanto
daquilo acreditar tanto no trabalho numa
coisa que ela se dedica o tempo todo
para fazer aqui um se dedica muito foi
muito suor em casamento
é mais ou menos enquanto você tá
dirigindo a bicicleta no começo tem que
pensar no que está fazendo tem que
treinar se tem que estudar e chega uma
hora que aquele conhecimento que está
estudando
numa região do cérebro que chama o
conhecimento pasto
esse conhecimento tácito acontecer pega
a bicicleta e não quero pensar pra de
pedalar a bicicleta acontece isso é uma
outra pesquisa das 10 horas os 10.000
anos à neurociência fala que se você
praticar a mesma coisa
o dez anos ou 10 mil horas ela vira esse
conhecimento tácito
isso vale para qualquer habilidade que
quer desenvolver qualquer ideia de
qualquer comunidade
e aí o trabalho com todos esses
conceitos e expliquei leva para um lugar
com incríveis mas o trabalho em rede
ainda mais poderoso e para explicar um
pouco com isso funciona a gente fez uma
analogia
imagine que somos todos os jogos a gente
conserta quantidade de trabalho a gente
se juntar a gente constrói um muro bom
muito forte pode durar muitos anos
aí vamos pouco a gente quer criar uma
coisa além de convidar alguém para
construir alguma coisa diferente nesse
muro mas já tem o resultado desse
trabalho é diferente
quando a gente tem um trabalho em rede
com tantas pessoas com tantas
habilidades diferentes pré dispostas a
se conectar construir algo maior
há coisas que acontecem poderes
incríveis e nem consegue imaginar a
proporção delas quando a gente está
construído ea moto é um pouco isso
ela podia ser só uma loja ela pedisse a
uru mas ela é muito mais do que isso
são várias pessoas construíram juntos
algo que eles acreditam mas com muito
trabalho isso vamos trabalhar
[Aplausos]
[Música]